alicia está a cargo del menú de la cena
del baile de graduación y quiere usar un
intervalo a partir de una muestra con
base en puntaje z para estimar la
proporción de graduados que podrían
pedir el menú vegetariano aleatoriamente
eligió a 30 de los 150 graduados y
encontró que 7 de ellos prefieren el
menú vegetariano cuáles son las
condiciones para construir un intervalo
de confianza que se cumplen con la
muestra de alicia elige todas las
respuestas que apliquen bien pausa el
vídeo e inténtalo ok vamos a trabajarlos
juntos seguramente lo primero que te
preguntas es que es un intervalo a
partir de una muestra con base en
puntajes z bueno lo puedes interpretar
como el intervalo de confianza que se
construye a partir de una muestra se
llama intervalos
pues su construcción está basada en los
intervalos de confianza es decir tomarás
un cierto número de desviaciones
estándar por arriba y por abajo del
parámetro el cual estás intentando
estimar y usarás esto para crear tus
inferencias por otro lado el número de
desviaciones estándar por arriba y por
abajo de cierto valor es lo que se suele
llamar como puntaje z o simplemente como
variable zeta recuerda estamos
intentando construir un intervalo de
confianza y para ello necesitamos hacer
algunas suposiciones primero tenemos una
población de 150 graduados por aquí y
bueno a alícia le resulta poco práctico
preguntarle a los 150 graduados para
obtener la verdadera proporción de la
población pero en cambio lo que hacen es
tomar una muestra de 30 grados es decir
n es igual a 30
de estos graduados encuentran que la
proporción de la muestra que quiere el
menú vegetariano son 7 de las 30
personas que están en la muestra
y con esto a partir de cierto nivel de
confianza ella construirá su intervalo
de confianza ahora recordemos las
condiciones que mencionamos en vídeos
anteriores primero tenemos que estar
convencidos de que esta es una muestra
aleatoria esta es la condición de
aleatoriedad y es justo lo que nos dice
la opción a los datos son una muestra
aleatoria de la población que nos
interesan
acaso sabemos esto bueno el texto nos
dice esto aleatoriamente eligió a 30 de
los 150 graduados así que vamos a decir
que si no podemos saber con exactitud
qué método utilizar pero lo vamos a
tomar literal así que en efecto el
inciso am es parte de nuestra respuesta
los datos son una muestra aleatoria de
la población que nos interesa si dijera
le pregunto solo al equipo de fútbol
bueno no sería una muestra aleatoria
pero estamos suponiendo que si bien
veamos el inciso b bueno esta siguiente
condición parece muy matemática pero es
sólo la condición normal déjame
apuntarlo es la condición normal y la
idea detrás de esta condición es suponer
que la distribución muestral de
proporciones se comporta aproximadamente
como una normal y por lo tanto no es
asimétrica a la derecha o asimétrica a
la izquierda y lo que nos dice es que el
tamaño de la muestra por la proporción
de los que quieren comida vegetariana
debe de ser mayor o igual a 10 y también
el tamaño de la muestra por la
proporción de los que no quieren comida
vegetariana debe de ser mayor o igual a
otra forma de pensarlo es que el número
de éxitos en nuestra muestra debe de ser
mayor o igual a 10 y también el número
de fracasos en nuestra muestra debe de
ser mayor o igual
a 10 así que cuantos éxitos tenemos
bueno tenemos 7 éxitos es justo lo que
nos dicen aquí siete éxitos lo puedes
ver así tenemos una muestra de 30
individuos y a esto lo multiplicamos por
siete de los graduados que queden comida
vegetariana de los 30 que están en
nuestra muestra entonces éste cuando
éste se va y así obtengo este 7 entonces
nuestros éxitos son menores que 10 y por
lo tanto no cumplimos la condición
normal recuerda esto es sólo una regla
general que en este caso nos dice que
nuestra distribución muestral podría ser
asimétrica esto basándonos en una
muestra aérea que dice tenemos un
intervalo a partir de la muestra con
base en puntaje z podríamos estar
equivocados pero creo que nos sentimos
bastante seguros de que no cumplimos
esta condición normal y por lo tanto
podemos cancelarla
después tengo las observaciones
individuales pueden considerarse
independientes bueno hay dos formas en
las que podrían ser independientes la
primera si ella eligió personas al azar
con reemplazo y la segunda si las
personas que eligió es decir la
población muestral es menor que el 10%
de la población total en ambos casos las
observaciones se consideran
independientes aunque no tengamos una
independencia perfecta veamos aquí
eligió a 30 de los 150 graduados por lo
tanto nuestra muestra es de 30 de los
150 graduados y esto es lo mismo que un
quinto y esto es lo mismo que el 20% lo
que quiere decir que como es más grande
que el 10% entonces concluimos otra vez
que no estamos cumpliendo la tercera
condición la condición de independencia
podremos cumplir esta condición
independiente
si el muestreo hubiera sido con
reemplazo lo cual no parece ser cierto o
si este porcentaje el porcentaje de la
muestra que tomamos en comparación de la
población general es menor al 10% por lo
tanto también podemos cancelar este
tercer inciso y bueno como no cumplimos
dos de las tres condiciones para tener
un intervalo de confianza válido podemos
concluir que el análisis del inicial no
es del todo correcto nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo